Palantir should be dissolved. That's what should happen. Silicon
Valley must play a role in addressing violent crime. Many politi-
Oh god, not the No.
That's terrifying. As that famous tweet goes, I would rather
serve crack than serve this country.
All right, let's let's give this Palantir memo a quick read through.
All right.
Cuz we get asked a lot. The Technological Republic in brief.
So, this is like their manifesto on how they see America moving
forward, okay?
Silicon Valley owes a moral debt to the country that made its
rise possible. The engineering elite of Silicon Valley has an
affirmative obligation to participate in the defense of the nation.
Two, we must rebel against the tyranny of the apps. Is the iPhone
our greatest creative, if not crowning, achievement as a civilization?
The object has changed our lives, and it may also now be limiting
and constraining our sense of the possible. I mean, I think that's
true. Three, free email is not enough. The decadence of culture
or of a culture or civilization, and indeed its ruling class,
will be forgiven only if the culture is capable of delivering
economic growth and security for the
I mean, that's true, sure. Feels a little Feels a little like
um cold to hear said that way, but sure. The limits of soft power
of soaring rhetoric alone have been exposed. The ability of free
and democratic societies to prevail requires something more than
a moral appeal. It requires hard power, and hard power in this
century will be built on software. Yeah, possibly. Probably.
The question is not whether AI weapons will be built. It is who
will build them and for what purpose.
Our adversaries will not pause to indulge in theatrical debates
about the merits of developing technologies with critical military
and national security applications. They will proceed.
Oh, boy. You guys do need to read Sun-Eater, okay?
You guys do. You need to learn about the demons, the daemons,
all right? National service should be a universal duty. We should,
as a society, could seriously consider moving away from an all-volunteer
force and only fight next war if everyone shares in the risk
and
That's very funny.
Mandatory military service from
I mean, okay, maybe.
if Silicon Valley wants to invest in rebuilding the infrastructure
of the country at just the cost to themselves and to nobody else
and make that their form of taxes, then you know what? Maybe.
But they need to start they need to invest first. You invest
first and then the US people will follow up, okay? Go and rebuild
like all build dams, build power plants, build bridges, repave
roads, repave highways, right? Rebuild everything. And then after
that, if everything's really cool, then mandatory military service
for every person.
Right? I I'd be okay with that. I just feel like it's going to
be mandatory military service and a commitment to build stuff,
maybe, and then nothing will get built. If a US Marine asks for
a better rifle, we should build it.
And the same goes for software. We should be a country or we
should as a country be capable of continuing a debate about the
appropriateness of military action abroad while remaining unflinching
in our commitment to those who have who we have asked to step
into harm's way.
Uh sure.
So this is like a vision for America, what it means to be American.
So at a base level, already quite a bit better than Democrats,
okay? At least it's something. At least it's some vision for
the world.
You know what I'm saying?
It might be horrifying, but it's something. Palantir is pseudo-government
outlet who is owned by someone that sees technology as a method
of subverting
And in his Peter Thiel's mind, this is the goal, a positive thing.
Yeah, I know. I'm very well aware of who Peter Thiel is and what
Palantir is. I'm also going to engage with these ideas as they're
written and not immediately read all of that in.
And we can read that in. We will read that in. But I'm going
to read it first and see how it sounds.
Okay, public servants need not be our priests. Any business that
compensated its employees in the way that the federal government
compensates public servants would struggle to survive. Okay,
that basically public servants are poppers. I
Any replaceable worker is not making any money these days. This
is true. This is basically saying that you're like a popper if
you are a public servant. Like you don't make very much money.
And so basically there's no elite human capital in politics because
it's dog money. It's like you don't earn anything. You don't
make anything. You can't build anything. People do it, but through
corruption.
We should show far more grace towards those who have subjected
themselves to public life. The eradication of any space for forgiveness,
a jettisoning of any tolerance for the complexities and contradictions
of the human psyche may leave us with a cast
of characters at the helm that we will grow to regret.
I mean, sure, it depends on what we're talking about here.
I guess the fact that you're constantly having your life combed
through affects things. That could be true. I'm trying to think
of how I look at that otherwise. That could be true that having
your life combed through prevents you from going to public life.
But also it's like, you know,
Stahl was not dealing with the complexities of the human psyche,
right? Like there is some amount of, "Hey, these are unacceptable
behaviors and we're not going to be super nuanced in in analyzing
them. You are being a piece of [__] and that really
can't be forgiven in this case. Sorry, man.
The psychol the the psycholog the
of modern politics is leading us astray. Those who took or so
those who look to the political arena to nourish their soul and
sense of self, who rely too heavily on their internal life finding
expression in people they may ever meet, will be left disappointed.
Is this moving away from influencer culture?
Those who look to the political arena to nourish their soul and
sense of self, who rely too heavily on their on their internal
life finding expression in people they may never meet will be
left
If you're like this is like politics is religion and the influencer
stuff put
I feel like you can't rely on politics to give you meaning in
life. You can't rely on all this stuff. If you do you are going
to be very unhappy. I think that's probably true and yet
I this will be where I question. I will very obviously question
why you want me looking away from politics when it's a Palantir
publishing this, right?
Like basically at a at a base level immediately very questionable,
very concerning. What is going on here exactly? Our society has
grown too eager to hasten and is often gleeful at the demise
of its enemies. The vanquishing of an opponent is the a moment
to pause, not rejoice.
Sure, but I always feel that way.
When somebody I dislike loses I'm always hesitant to dance on
their grave. I don't know. That one that one I feel like doesn't
apply to me. I also don't know how that plays out as a societal
thing. Okay.
We'll we'll come back through this stuff again after we talk
for a little bit. The atomic age is ending. One age of deterrence,
the atomic age, is ending and a new age of deterrence built on
AI is set to begin. Ooh, I hate this. I hate this. I hate this.
I hate this. This could be true, but I hate this a lot. I hate
this a lot because the updates here could be significantly
and more consequential than anything else. Like essentially once
you get to the stage where
I understand a lot of people think AGI is fake, but if you were
to get to something like AGI and you could use AI to uncover
something new in material science such that you could produce
a weapon that could theoretically eliminate your enemies before.
Like what happens with
non-proliferation or and whatever. What what happens with deterrence?
When one country invents a weapon that can immediately vanquish
all of its enemies
more or Like if we if we're able to construct this, if we're
able to build it in just the right way, we could destroy everybody
who's against us, and they could just be gone
What prevents people from hitting that No other country in the
history of the world has advanced progressive values more than
this one. The United States is far from perfect, but it is easy
to forget how much more opportunity exists in this country for
those who are not hereditary elites than in any other nation
on the planet. See, this is
and we need to keep it that way. Needs to be included in this.
And this is the most important value of the country. This is
the most important thing. This is fundamental
to America, and it's what differentiates America from Europe
and other Western countries. Is that in Europe, you are far less
likely to ever have economic like significant economic mobility
where you could reach the upper crust of society? That is not
a thing in Europe anywhere near as much as it is a thing in America.
and this
this needs to remain true. If this becomes untrue, like everything
is broken at that point. American power has made it possible
has made possible an extraordinarily long
Too many have have forgotten or perhaps take for granted that
nearly a century of some version of peace has prevailed in the
world without a great military conflict. Great power military
conflict, sorry. At least three generations, billions of people,
and their children and now grandchildren have never known a world
war.
I Okay, are these like chastisements? I feel like these are chastisements.
Technological republic in brief. That like I guess the implication
here is a hegemonic power, a an overwhelming hegemonic power
is what gives us peace.
And so we need to remain the overwhelming hegemonic power, right?
So all of this is going to point towards a lack of AI restriction,
uh a total like a moving of the country as a mechanism to further
AI. Hey, we need to get the government more involved in building
power power structure, power infrastructure, and data centers
because AI will be how we win this war. And if we don't do that,
we're going to fall behind. We remain the global hegemonic power
by investing in this stuff, building it out, and being and leading
the way.
And that anybody who's talking about not doing that doesn't realize
the existential risk that you're putting us in, the you're you're
exposing us to. The post-war neutering of Germany and Japan must
be undone. The defanging of Germany was an overcorrection for
which Europe is now paying a heavy price. A similar and highly
theatrical commitment to Japanese pacifism will, if maintained,
also threaten to shift the balance of power in Asia. I this is
Is Japan not undergoing its biggest military build-up like ever
in its history? Japan is like trying to build out their navy
massively. Like they've not done anything like this since World
War II. Am I Am I wrong on this? This feels like What the [__]
are we talking about? Is this not like incoherent with reality?
Like not mhm. Okay. We should applaud those who attempt to build
where the market has failed to act. The culture almost snickers
at Musk's interest in grand narrative, as if billionaires ought
to simply stay in their lane of enriching themselves. Any curiosity
or genuine interest in the wake of what has what he has created
is essentially diminished or dismissed, sorry, or perhaps lurks
from beneath a thinly veiled scorn.
Um I
I tried to do this, but Elon was too cringe. I tried to say that
like I do think it's cool the things he's done. Elon just got
too cringe in in the other direction, right? Like if Elon hadn't
done his buy of X and then his explicit weaponizing of X to steal
the or not steal, but to influence the 2024 election. If he'd
not done that, I could have kept saying like, oh yeah, Starlink's
awesome. Like it's it's really awesome some of these things he
did. Although he totally violated like standard standards and
protocols to get all of this stuff done.
I could have kept defending him, but then he became an so. Silicon
Valley must play a role in addressing violent crime. Many politi-
Oh god, not the No.
>> That's terrifying.
Immediately.
That feels like that's immediately
surveillance state, right? That's the first thing I hear here
is surveillance state. When they say, "Silicon Valley must play
a role in addressing violent
How are they going to do that? With Starlink and acquisition?
I I'm sure it was in some way. I'm sure he wasn't involved from
the beginning. "Silicon Valley must play a role in addressing
violent crime. Many politicians across the United States have
essentially shrugged when it comes to violent crime, abandoning
any serious efforts to address the problem or take on or take
on any risk when with their constituencies or donors in coming
up with solutions and experiments in what should be a desperate
bid to save
Violent crime, I believe, is at the lowest it's like Violent
crime is essentially consistently going
What it What is this? This seems disconnected.
This seems disconnected again. I'm not sure where you're going
with this one. What's going on there, man?
What is that? That's weird.
Okay. All right. "The ruthless exposure of the private lives
of public figures drives far too much talent away from government
service,
the public arena, and the shallow and petty assaults against
those who dare to do something other than enrich themselves have
become so unforgiving that the republic is left with a significant
roster of ineffectual empty vessels whose ambition one would
forgive if there were any genuine belief structure lurking within."
You're calling all all politicians empty suits, but then when
did this happen? When did the ruthless exposure become a thing?
It's It's not that It's not this. Bro, this is This is total
cope, too. I don't know what this is. I don't know what this
point's supposed to be, but this is complete cope. You just can't
enrich yourself massively.
That's why people don't go into public service is because if
you are willing to if you are an effective and
I would say
unprincipled person more than an ideological person, I think
you used to go into politics, but you are now far more incentivized
to go to Wall Street or go to Silicon
You can buy you can enrich yourself and and gain power far faster
in those places. It's just a market force. The caution in public
life that we unwittingly encourage is corrosive. Those who say
nothing wrong often say nothing much at all. Um that's true.
But I think
man, shouldn't we be
I totally agree with that.
But you'd think that's going to be something people will get
better at. I I have seen no evidence of it, but you think that's
something people will get better at. I think that's the aversion
you see to some like plat wrapped in plastic candidates who have
like no problems. I think I think people like like that was that
was how I felt about Hillary Clinton. I don't know if any everybody
felt that way. I don't think they do. But like with Hillary it
seemed like she was just wrapped in plastic. Like there was not
a lot there. I don't know.
I don't know. Interesting. I I like maybe understand this that
you can't really say anything because you're trying to remain
politically correct.
But I I again this has to be talked about. I I don't know how
you fix this. This is a tough one. The pervasive intolerance
of the religious belief in certain circles must be resisted.
The elites' intolerance of religious belief is perhaps one of
the most telling signs that its political project constitutes
a less open intellectual movement than many within it would
21, some cultures have produced vital advances, others remain
dysfunctional and regressive. All cultures are not equal. Criticism
and value judgments are forbidden. Yet this new dogma glosses
over the fact that certain cultures and indeed so-called cultures
have produced wonders. Others have proven middling and worse
regressive and harmful. I wonder which ones I wonder which ones
these are. I can see why so many progressives were against this
now. This is I a lot of this stuff I was like, okay, maybe maybe
it's like fine. Maybe it's maybe this is not so bad. And then
I get to this one I'm like, oh. Oh, I see. I see where progressives
got mad at this. I see it now. Yeah, that makes sense. I get
it. I get it a little bit.
We must resist the shallow temptation of a vacant and hollow
and hollow
pluralism.
We in America are more broad and more broadly the West have for
the past half century resisted defining national cultures in
the name of inclusivity, but inclusion into what? Worst aspiring
philosopher king ever.
>> Dude, I do love that Where is it? Where is this one?
Those who say wrong often say nothing much at all. I do think
that that you're almost other than maybe the cultural thing,
I feel like there's a lot of hiding in what these people mean
here.
You know what I'm saying? Yes, yes, it dude Palantir is not a
good company. They're not like a broadly high high moral value
company, okay? I'm trying to think a couple of these are pretty
spooky. Like when you take certain ones of them and just run
them to their end
it is like national service should be a universal duty. Oh man,
and just like the the police state implication, national service
implication
the other thing was I guess people need to be taken care of for
the elites in society to live the lives they want to lead. It's
very bread and circuses, too. I can I can see what they're going
for. There is some elements this feels very Yarvin-esque
is how this feels to me. Like it is talking about, you know
How do you How do you get to this? Check out some of the longer
quote tweets. They're very interesting. I might look up some
of the videos on this, too. Please let me spy on you. Abolish
Palantir.
Like I'm just I'm trying to engage with the ideas. I don't want
to just hate it because it's Peter Thiel. You know what I'm saying?
I'm trying I do want to engage with the ideas. I don't want to
just go crazy on this. So hold on, let me go and check out
>> of uh Palantir. Palantir is basically an evil company
that can accurately be described as Skynet Skynet from the Terminator
series.
Their [laughter] laundry list of crimes
>> I do think like just the fact that they're already engaging
in surveillance against American citizens very concerning, right?
So deeply embedded in the government very concerning. >> is
endless. There's a a lot of evidence to support for selling the
idea that they were helping with the genocide in
They're involved with AI weapons. They're involved with mass
surveillance and illegal spying literally creating a blackmail
file on the American people. We covered the story of one of the
founders who basically said like we created Palantir to kill
leftists. I'm not even kidding. You know, we covered that when
that dropped. I forget the guy's name who said it but one of
the other co-founders of Palantir. And of course, you know, Peter
Thiel this is his baby. Peter Thiel's a very very disturbing
guy
fundamentally anti-human. That's his his ideology. That's his
mindset. That's his philosophy. It's it's an anti-human perspective
that says we basically need to be replaced by AI by machines
that you know, that humans are just too flawed and we shouldn't
continue as we are. He was asked directly like
>> Okay, I do think we should also watch something to do
with Peter Thiel here at some point like Plant Dad suggested
because realistically, I never know how much Peter Thiel is being
like straw manned in these conversations. I am a little concerned
when I'm watching like Lefty media and they talk about Peter
Thiel. I do not think they could see him objectively but also
I think I don't think their objective analysis is off either.
Like I think their analysis might be on point entirely but I
don't think it's from an objective place. So I need like another
counterpoint. You know what I'm saying? Like they might be I
I have a feeling that they are very very very accurate. I just
know it's bias but it doesn't mean they're inaccurate.
I just need somebody else I need to hear somebody else talk about
him too or hear him speak. One of the two. I also just know that
he is like a very off-putting person to listen to speak, so it's
concerning. >> know, should the human species continue?
And he basically
>> Um yeah, it sounds like it sounds like Palantir's pretty
embedded in the British government as well. Yeah, that's what
people are saying. >> Basically debated and stuttered and
was "I don't know. I guess. I guess." It was very, very disturbing.
Everybody saw that interview with Ross doubt that. And it did
not go well for Peter Thiel. Well, there's this guy named Alex
Karp
who helps run Palantir. He's that guy that's got the goofy-ass
crazy hair and he never sits still and it looks like he does
a ridiculous amount of And then when he was called out on to
clearly doing he does this whole like, "Oh, no. I I just I'm
just like or something." Like he tries to, you know, mask it
behind this idea of like, "I'm just an eccentric
genius or something like that." Just humiliating. Well, anyway,
that guy um is incredibly disturbing. And like I said, seems
to be a a rampant drug addict. Well, guess what? He basically
took some time to write a manifesto,
a screed that he thought the world should see. >> Dude,
screed is such a good word, isn't
Like you can't not If somebody wrote a screed, you can't not
think they're schizophrenic. They're like automatically schizophrenic
if they wrote a screed.
It's such a great word. I love it. >> Okay? We're going
to go through it here and all I'm going to say is prepare yourselves
because here you have a
evil, disturbing company that should not exist
that's all about AI weaponry and spying on innocent people and
murder. It's like murder incorporate.
>> Oh, man.
This going to be rough. This is where I lose the other half of
the audience, isn't it?
I You got to engage with the argument that deterrence might be
through AI.
You've got to engage with that argument,
You You actually might. You got to engage with it. It could be
the case. That could be a thing. Anyway, we got to we got to
keep listening, but >> No disrespect to John and Kyle,
all right? But you get the point. >> Well, listen to what
he says here. This is crazy. >> Because we get asked a
lot, the Technological Republic in brief. Number one, Silicon
Valley owes a moral debt to the country that made its rise possible.
The engineering elite of Silicon Valley has an affirmative obligation
to participate in the defense of the >> So that's them
trying to justify doing AI weapons. They're trying to say, "Oh,
it's like the moral thing to do to create these machines of death."
Okay, they continue. Number two, "We must rebel against the tyranny
of the apps." What? "Is the iPhone our greatest creative, if
not crowning achievement as a civilization? The object has changed
our lives, but it may also now be limiting and constraining our
sense of the possible." Hey, but you're also a tech company.
What the [__] you talking about? All right, they
>> That's See, that's not engagement. Do you know what
I'm talking That's not engagement at all.
That Those points Those are just objectively true facts. Why
is he saying them? That's where you could get into like disagreeing.
But the the second one, that's just like objectively true. What
are we doing, man? That That part's just objectively true. That
like, "Hey, you are giving way too much attention to your phone.
Your phone gets way too much of your attention and other things
get none of your attention and it's probably [__]
up everybody." I I don't Like, you shouldn't have some sort of
Palantir mandated thing, but at some point people have to realize
that like this is becoming
all encompassing. >> a moral debt to the country that made
its rise possible. The engineering elite of Silicon Valley has
an affirmative obligation to participate in the defense of the
nation." >> So that's them trying to justify doing AI weapons.
They're trying to say, "Oh, it's like the moral thing to do to
create these machines of
>> Yeah, we finished reading it on our own. We're at the
bottom. But
I lost it. X Palantir.
Wait, really? Yeah, we watch we read all of it. I'm almost positive
we read all of it. Hold on.
Yeah, we definitely read all of it. Back to Kyle. Death. Okay,
they continue. Number two. We must rebel against the tyranny
of the apps. What? Is the iPhone our greatest creative, if not
crowning achievement as a civilization? The object has changed
our lives, but it may also now be limiting and constraining our
sense of the possible. Hey, but you're also a tech company. What
the [__] you talking about? All right, they continue.
Free email is not enough. The decadence of of a culture or civilization,
and indeed its ruling class, will be forgiven only if that culture
is capable of delivering economic growth and security for the
public. By the way, you can tell that the person who wrote this
is thinking it's like grandiose thinking. You're all thinking
you have the most brilliant idea ever, and then you come back
to it, you know, the next morning when you're not high anymore
and you go, "What the [__] is this?" Babble. Number
four.
Man, just I I can see how this is going to go. I see what it
is. You guys want to make fun of this loser.
Which he deserves, okay? Alex Karp sucks. Let's just go pull
up a video. Just pull up the video of him like showing his swords
to that girl. I'm pretty sure he had like a a Palmer Luckey-esque
interview with some attractive woman where he like pulls his
ninja swords out for her. It's dude, just go look at that. Let's
just go watch him be a loser. If you just want to start this
guy, let's just go snark him directly. But if if you're talking
about ideas, you should engage with the ideas. The limits of
soft power, of soaring rhetoric alone, have been exposed. The
ability of free and democratic societies to prevail require something
more than moral appeals. It requires hard power, and hard power
in this century will be built on software. Now we're getting
demonic, right? We're not We're not Soft power isn't enough.
We need hard power. We need war. We need death. That's what we
need. And what they're saying is, we build the weapons of death.
We we build the AI weapons of death. So, you kind of need us.
All right, they continue. The question is not whether AI weapons
will be built. It is who will build them and for what purpose.
Our adversaries will not pause to indulge in theatrical debates
about the merits of developing technologies with critical military
and national security applications. They will proceed. In other
words, hey, China's going to do it anyway. There's others that
are going to do the these incredibly immoral, unethical, disturbing
things. So, we need to do it, too. That's literally what they're
saying here. All right, number six. National service should be
a universal duty. What? We should as a society consider moving
away from an all Okay, this is one of the ones where I'm like,
why are they arguing for this?" It sounds like they want to do
To be honest, you call it the Technological Republic. I feel
like this is a Rome LARPer tech bros manifesto, right? He wants
to be Caesar. He thinks he's Caesar. Like, Pax Romana, but Pax
Americana.
Might through the sword. We're going to go we're going to resubdue
the entirety of humanity. That's That's how I hear this. That's
how it reads.
That's more what it is when you include the the national service
and oh, it's our duty to take care of the plebs.
Right? That's That's what I'm hearing. That's what I'm seeing.
>> and only fight the next war if everyone shares in the
risk and the cost. You have got to kidding me. Modern-day Skynet,
the AI machine of death creators, the universal
the blackmail
surveillance network, they're now coming out saying, "Everybody
should be forced to go fight and die for Israel." Yes, that's
what needs to happen. Yes.
Are you [laughter] [__] kidding me? A [__]
draft? Do you have any idea how quickly I would be out this [__]
if there was a draft? Do Do have any idea how quickly
like probably millions of Americans would be >> Uh not
good. Not good rhetoric. Not good rhetoric at all. >> this
[__] if there was a draft?
As that famous tweet goes, I would rather serve crack than serve
this country. Are you kidding me? We waged an >> Oh, such
Oh, such bad rhetoric. Oh, no.
Yikes, Kyle.
This is why
I I get where he's coming from. I I mean, I wouldn't want to
be conscripted in the military, but at some point you might need
it. I think there's better things to engage with here, right?
Oh, a draft like if we're not in wartime, are we just starting
a war? We're just going to go start a war? Like you'd have to
have, you know, we can draft if we have some need if we can define
some need if there's some need we could describe to the American
people such that
I don't know. Such that like maybe there's a referendum and people
decide that we're going to all go we have to go we have to fight
this war or something. But honestly,
this feels weird to me to just go like no, a draft is totally
wrong. I'll never I'll never serve this country ever. >> an
illegal and offensive war against a country that didn't attack
us. They were no threat to us whatsoever.
They had a >> I do think the Iran war would be one where
you'd get like a significant por- Like maybe there's a referendum
to cancel out a draft that if enough of the population's like
no no no no no, no thank you. You know what I mean? >> agreed
to our strictest requirements on their enriched uranium. But
just a couple hours before we attacked them. Okay? We triple
tapped a girl school. We bombed schools, we bombed hospitals,
we bombed bridges, we bombed power plants, we bombed a pharmaceutical
company, we bombed steel plants. Trump's threatening to have
quote a whole civilization die.
And I'm sure you know we're the good guys. Why? Why how? How
the [__] are we the good guys? You need to I know
your actions matter. And you want people you want to force
innocent men to be presumably men. I don't know if they also
want women to go, but like you want to innocent people to be
sent there to [__] die. For what?
For what? For your profits? For Palantir's profits? Go yourself.
By the way, the nerve. Why the [__] should I care
about your thoughts on a draft?
any more than I would care about Burger King's thoughts on a
draft, right? Like CVS is opposed to a draft. Like why the [__]
would I care? You're a soulless corporation that profits off
of misery and death and and violations of privacy. Why should
I give a single solitary what the [__] you think
about anything?
Right? Nobody elected you. Nobody supports you. Jesus Christ,
what is wrong with these people? Oh my god, bro. This I'm sorry.
>> We we need to get to the point where if if a company
is viewed as against
the actual national interest, you should be able to dissolve
that right? Palantir should be dissolved. That's what should
happen. All right, we're not >> Uh I think that's a conversation
that could be had. That like hey, this this corporation seems
to be like I do think there's a way you would argue or way you
talk about this where you it's reasonable to believe
that there's a cadre of elites in the United States who are working
as a fifth column without explicitly acting like a fifth column.
That they're pretending to support the United States and are
pushing for things that will eventually balkanize the United
States. And if you can identify them and call them out, then
dissolving their their companies, seizing their assets could
be valid. But you have to you have to make that argument cuz
that is absolutely taking away people's liber- taking away people's
liberties, right? Like it's a very illiberal thing that Americans
don't do. So
I don't disagree that Palantir could be evil. I might even agree
that Palantir is evil or the people behind it certainly are.
But you got to you got to be able to lay it out. >> Not done
yet though. They say number seven, if a US Marine asks for a
better rifle, we should build it and the same goes for software.
We should as a country be cap- capable of continuing a debate
about the appropriateness of military action abroad while remaining
unflinching in our commitment to those we have asked to step
into harm's way. I don't know what this means other than hey,
you really probably shouldn't debate this. You should shut the
[__] up and fall in line is the subtext of that I
believe. Number eight, public servants need not be our priests.
Any business that compensated its employees in the way that the
federal government compensated public servants would struggle
to survive. Number nine, we should show far more grace towards
those who have subjected themselves to public life. The eradication
of any space for forgiveness, a jettisoning of any tolerance
for complexities and contradictions of the human psyche may leave
us with a cast of characters as at the helm we will grow to regret.
Is he just saying like stop criticizing politicians cuz that's
kind of what I'm getting out of this? And is it by extension
shut the [__] up, stop criticizing Trump, stop criticizing
Netanyahu? Is that what this is? We should show far more grace
to those who have subjected themselves to public
>> I I also thought this was like weird. I was like, can
you give me an example of someone who's had like the the
Al Franken? Is Al Franken the only one? I think it's like Al
Franken is the the only person I can think of here who this would
apply to, who got like a little bit too much, who didn't get
enough
Other than that, I I like I can't think of anyone. >> how
about they should show far more grace to the American people
who are getting perpetually and routinely [__] with
a spiky metal bat by them? How about that? How about they should
actually represent us and give us universal health care and free
college and a living wage and they should end the wars and they
should do a green new deal and they should do universal daycare
and they should tax the rich. How about that? Why did Why do
we have to show them grace when they're [__] everything
up but they don't have to show us grace and actually do their
jobs and rep >> Well, actually, that is Is that not the
next point or one of the next like three
That's one of the Maybe it was earlier than that. Hold on.
Where was that point? Cuz there's a point about three meals out
enough,
That's That is the point they're making is is actually we need
to take care of
That is that is attached in here. That's why I'm like man, I
all evil, but you're making criticisms that probably don't apply
here as much. Now, you could just say we can't trust anything
they say as well. I suppose, but it is it's technically >> represent
us. Number 10, the psychologicalization of modern politics is
leading us astray. Again, you could tell this guy's high on This
is
Those who look to the political arena to nourish their soul and
sense of self who rely too heavily on their internal life finding
expression in people they may never meet will be left disappointed.
Number 11, our society has grown too eager to hasten and is often
gleeful at the demise of its enemies. What? The vanquishing of
an opponent is a moment to pause, not rejoice. Number 12, the
atomic age is ending. One age of deterrence, the atomic age,
is ending and a new era of deterrence built on AI is set to begin.
13, no other country in the history of the world has advanced
progressive values more than this one. Says the mass surveillance
network that builds AI machines of death. The United States is
far from perfect, but it is easy to forget how much more opportunity
exists in this country for those who are not hereditary elites
than in any other nation on the planet. This is just total We
do not have free health care in this country. We do not have
free college in this country. Uh we rank very low actually when
it comes to develop countries on uh you know climbing the economic
ladder on this notion that we typically would call the American
dream. We actually rank very low on that in developed countries.
This is just total In many ways there's much less opportunity
that exists here. I mean, the fact that you have to pay health
insurance companies as just a parasite middleman who deny your
claims anyway, I mean, it's literally like a scam. The insurance
industry is like a scam in this country. Like half the country
can afford a $500 emergency. How the [__] can you
say that oh this country is packed with opportunity? Like those
days have long passed us by. We are declining as a civilization
rapidly and you're just pretending like that's not the case.
It's humiliating. >> Like ogre boy, that's not what they're
saying here. The The atomic age is over point is about how these
weapons are going to be built and weapons that have like the
ability to use AI.
Like certain like guidance systems, interceptors, stuff like
this that if you're not building them and other countries are,
you'll just quickly be rolled over by those countries. And so
everybody is nukes pointed at each other. But I like there's
a there's a meta point here which is if AI is being used in research
and there's a compelling way to do it and you're making advances
in material science that humanity has never been able to. Like
so like what if what if AI is used to solve that in some way?
General relativity, thank you. What if AI is used to solve that
in some way? Like resolve these things. And it makes sense it
works in a way that humans probably basically
basically like can't conceive. And you use that to make advancements
in material science that humanity previously was incapable of
that allow you to build weapons that can take advantage of AI
even further and do crazy [__]
I don't know the time scale. Well, the whole point of AI is you
don't know the time scale. The time scale will rapidly jump forward.
At the point where they're able to figure these things out, the
time scale will leap forward
These gains will Technological gains are basically universally
exponential. As you make a a technological gain, it enables further
technological gain. And
the the scary thing here is if you're not doing this, you are
basically It's basically like they're they're proposing that
it is the new atomic race and if you don't start a Manhattan
project, you're [__] That is sort of what they're
going for here. They're They're arguing this is the new atomic
race. This is the new like we're racing to build the bomb and
if you do not build a Manhattan project, we're all dead. We could
all be dead.
And it's like, okay, that's interesting. That's possible.
I don't know. That Certainly that's very difficult to throw into
something like this. But I do believe that's even more so what
that's meant or sorry what's meant by this cuz he already talked
about AI weapons earlier. Yeah. I when he talks about deterrence
built on AI I do believe he's talking about the combination of
scientific gains and future weapons research. >> All right,
we're almost done. Number 14 America American power has made
possible an extraordinarily long peace. Too many have forgotten
or perhaps taken for granted that nearly a century of some version
of peace has prevailed in the world without a great power military
conflict. At least three generations billions of people and their
children and now grandchildren have never known a world war.
So they're saying oh America is because of America a strong America
that we have peace. Yeah, say that to the people in all of the
countries that we bombed and attacked and did regime change in.
No, that's not true. In the Imperial core that's relatively true,
but outside of the Imperial core that is not at all true. Okay,
go talk Oh, he talked about the Imperial core. Uh-oh. When we
said Kyle was just a
Kyle's saying Imperial core now. Oh God. Kyle, no. Kyle, no.
We need to keep Kyle. You're my populist bro and now you're going
over to the socialist side. Kyle. >> Talk to the people
of Iraq. Go talk to the people of Libya. Go talk to the people
of Somalia. Go talk to the people of Yemen. Go talk to people
in South America who we routinely over in the Cold War. Like
this is just total naval gazing horse. Number 15 the post-war
neutering of Germany and Japan must be undone. The defanging
of Germany was an overcorrection for which Europe is now paying
a heavy price. Wow. It's kind of hard to read this as anything
other than the modern-day Nazi perspective, right? It's kind
of hard to read this as anything other than that. Oh, we should
have never taken the arms away from Germany and Japan. Well,
they were the fascist countries that were against us in World
War II. All right, number 16 makes no sense. I Hold on. Hold
on. You understand this is the exact same like line of logic
that a lot of people use to totally dismiss what Hassan's saying,
to just say he's like advocating for killing elites and stealing
in that interview instead of having like some sort of discussion
engagement with it. Like I can think that but I'm still going
to engage with the ideas on like as they're stated. If you don't
engage with the ideas as they're stated, then you have no idea
like how they're trying to manipulate these things or you get
a very poor idea of how they're trying to manipulate these things
to gain specific to get specific things, right? Like when they
talk about how okay, AI weapons could be built anywhere. That
is them basically trying to reinforce everybody that any AI regulation
is threatening the security of the United States. That they that
American people should tie the idea of AI regulation to these
people want to see America die and implode.
That's the goal they're going for, right? But if you just go
these people
I don't think you get you don't quite understand it. Refraining
Japan and Germany is specifically because those two nations have
been re-burgeoning nationalistic and fascistic identities.
I mean Japan's already rebuilding a military. Japan's been rebuilding
their military for like a I don't know, 5 years now.
I think Japan was doing this before this guy said anything.
16, we should applaud those who attempt to build where the mar
Um that's what I said, ogre boy. I said literally you can get
this stuff. If you want to have this deal where you have like
basically a set of patricians
who take care of America. You want to do that? Then start building
temples.
Like once you've built out a ton of power infrastructure, once
you've built out a ton of roads, you've repaved all of the roads,
rebuilt a bunch of bridges, re built dams, built nuclear power
plants. Once you've spent a significant portion of your wealth
doing
then you can have your set of proles, okay? You can have your
proletariat. You can have your plebs, all right? And we'll have
a patrician class and that's totally You know what I'm saying?
Like like invest first. If you want to even get there, start
investing. Start building start doing cool stuff for people.
Don't Don't act like okay, we want Rome. We want our Roman Republic.
But you don't actually do anything the patrician did, the the
the patrician class did.
Like you have to build the the society, you have to build up
the society again, cuz it's crumbling.
Give Give people something to hope for. I understand that that
might be it gives people something to hope for in a way that
like basically pushes them towards some kind of techno-fascist
state, and that's what everybody's worried about. But like build
something. They got to do something. It can't just be pretty
words and then like give us all the power and then we'll take
care of you. Right? That can't be what it is. You're not getting
my vote without any idea of what you're going to do.
Same Same principle applies, okay, to everybody. Market has failed.
The culture almost snickers at Musk's interest in grand narrative.
Oh my god, they're sucking off Elon Musk as if billionaires ought
to simply stay in their lane of enriching themselves. That's
what he's doing. Any curiosity or genuine interest in the value
of what he's created is essentially dismissed or perhaps lurks
from beneath a thinly veiled scorn. No, the reason why people
hate Elon Musk is because he illegally cut pediatric cancer research
and Meals on Wheels, and he destroyed everything good about our
government like the CFPB as he was walking around goose-stepping
and Sieg Heil-ing, and he's retweeting Nazis on a daily basis,
and he's taking $38 billion in US tax money for like 13 rockets
that instantly explode when they get up in space. The reason
we hate him is cuz he's a fraud, he's a con man, he's a liar,
he does vaporware like nobody's business. But this guy also,
Alex Karp, is also a liar and a con man. So of course he would
defend his fellow liar and con man, Elon Musk. Jesus
I I feel like Alex Karp is way more ideological than Elon Musk.
I feel like Elon Musk is like a bullied kid who just wants people
to like him.
And I get I get how all of his psychopathy is downstream of that.
Alex Karp, I get like way different vibes. I get like
like sinister
sinister vibes. Like he has he has like a goal and he is like
totally fine being mocked, doesn't care about how much people
like him. He's just going to be the guy who gets his goal accomplished.
>> All right, let me speed this up. I'm so sick of this
guy. Number 17, Silicon Valley must play a role in addressing
violent crime. What the [__] are you talking? Oh,
so now we're doing violent crime fear-mongering. >> This
This is like somebody already No, Kyle, think about how he wants
to do that. Kyle, think about what he's asking for. How is Silicon
Valley, a technol- a technology company, how are they going to
address violent crime? Kyle, what does that mean? >> I
agree. >> You have to engage here. >> Number 18,
the ruthless >> Oh, to start effectively you have to engage
there. Oh, come on, man. That's like Minority Report [__]
If you don't engage with what's being said there, that's like
Minority Report, right? That's we need to spy on people collect
enough data to prevent crimes. That's we need to be able to monitor
surveillance cameras to see violent violent crime's about to
occur. This is This is literally they're asking for insane [__]
right there. That's why you got to engage, right? >> Oh,
so now we're doing violent crime fear-mongering. Jesus Christ.
Number 18, the ruthless exposure of the private lives of public
figures drives far too much talent away from government
You You people are keeping a blackmail data file on everybody,
and you're talking about how the ruthless exposure of private
lives of public figures is bad? Like that's your whole business
model. Number
>> 19, the caution >> I also can't help but feel
like that's Peter Thiel.
It was really [__] up with people outed me as gay.
I feel like that's what it is. >> exposure of private lives
of public figures is bad? Like that's your whole business model.
Number 19, the caution in public life that we unwittingly encourage
is corrosive. Those who say nothing wrong often say nothing much
at all. Just babbling here. Number 20, the pervasive intolerance
of religious belief in certain circles must be
>> Hear me out. Palantir x Polymarket. The moment Palantir
detects a pre-crime, bets to live and people people can bet to
live or who lives, and people can watch it if it plays out. Basically,
we take the CCTV footage, we put it up, we go, "Hey, we think
this guy's about to stab somebody." And then immediately a video
goes up, and people have like 60 seconds to like 5 minutes to
watch it, and then place a bet. What's going to happen when this
guy when this guy pulls that knife out? What's happening right
Oh my god. >> intolerance of religious beliefs, what are
you talking about? It's perhaps one of the most telling signs
that its political project constitute a less open intellectual
movement than many within within it would claim. Palantir is
saying that there's elite intolerance of religious beliefs. Are
you kidding me? There's an over-religiosity
amongst elites. Trump is reading Bible verses from the White
House. What are you talking about? He's got like Paula White
probably on her knees in the White House and his hand her hand
on him praying for him with all the other Franklin Graham and
all
>> This is particularly weird to me, the religious element
being added in. >> I don't necessarily think religion's
like bad. I don't think religion is bad. I'm not like an atheist
like most people, but I I don't think I think religion is guiding
a lot of decision-making in the Middle East right now, and it's
>> What are you talking about? Mike Huckabee is the ambassador
to Israel, and he's saying that oh, when he in the Bible Israel
could have all the Middle East, so they should have all the Middle
East. How are you saying that oh, we're not religious enough?
We're like we're like atheist fundamentalists. What the [__]
is wrong with you? What world are you living in? Number 21, some
cultures have profound vital advances, others remain dysfunctional
and regressive. All cultures are now equal. Criticism and value
judgments are forbidden. Yet this new dogma glosses over the
fact that certain cultures and indeed subcultures have produced
wonders, others have proven middling and worse, regressive and
harmful. So now comes the Sieg Heil-ing and the goose-stepping
in your own respect. Literally doing the like, we're not actually
equal as people. Don't be ridiculous. No, some people are better
than other people, like us, the >> Not just that, Kyle,
but who who are the regressive cultures? >> AI machine
of death-creating blackmail data network. Uh we're special. We're
special, America's special, Israel's special. When we genocide
you, it's cuz we're the good guys and you're the bad guys and
your culture is inferior. That's That's what they're getting
at here. That's exactly what this is. Number 22, we must resist
the shallow temptation of a vacant and hollow pluralism. We in
America and more broadly the West have for the past half century
resisted defining national cultures in the name of inclusivity,
but inclusion into what? So, they say, "We must resist the shallow
temptation of a vacant and hollow pluralism." In other words,
pluralism is bad. Multiculturalism is bad. They want to be uh
homogeneous, is what that means. They want to be maybe one religion,
one ethnicity in the country. Here you have nominally a tech
company
that's uh literally out there going, uh "We're not all equal.
Some people are better than other people and multiculturalism,
pluralism, equality."
Um, yes, us, the country that makes the machines of death.
>> They're They're offering the trade. They're offering
the trade, okay?
We'll start reinvesting in this country so long as you accept
that we're like the patrician class. So long as we get some leeway,
we get some favors from government because we're the patrician
class, we will save this country. We'll start reinvesting in
it.
And how you want to react to that that fact
is up to you. But, I do believe that is essentially the the argument
here, or the what's going on. Listen, all of the If you ever
listen to these people, they talk about elite human capital all
the time, okay? Like basically the really intelligent people
who are next level and above everyone else. And they want basically
their right to be considered like a patrician class. They're
going to get some extra rights, they're going to get some extra
protections. And
in return, they'll reinvest in the country. They'll They'll reinvest,
they'll they'll put their money in, they'll try to fix everything.
But, also
maybe we need to go take over some places. I don't know. It's
very interesting. It's It's like interesting as in
I don't know why Alex Karpis saying >> And create blackmail
data files on everybody and it's trying to infiltrate you in
every element of your life. Yes, us modern day Skynet. And by
the way, the Alex Karp who did too much is giving away the game
here. He's giving away what Palantir is really about. Just like
oh yeah, the guy's name was Joel Joel Lonsdale, I think. Just
like he said, Palantir is about killing
Um never in my wildest imagination could I have thought that
these people could be this openly evil and destructive and
And yet here we are. That's exactly what they are. These people
should be nowhere near power. I don't care who the the next Democratic
president needs to
>> Is this brain dead commentary from Kyle? Well, it's
I mean it's not good engagement, but I don't think the funny
thing is is I don't think his intuitively I do believe he's correct
about Palantir's intentions.
The points are
bad. Like he's not engaging with any of the points or what they're
going to offer. And so messaging against it is quite difficult
when you just say these people are fundamentally evil and never
ever like talk to them or accept them or anything, right? I So
I man, it's it sucks cuz I probably agree with them. It's just
I'm not sure if this was great